[Music]
okay
[Music]
I turned into a teenage
that iconic scene of Jenna Ortega
Dancing In Netflix's Wednesday has
people talking yet again but this time
for a very different reason in a new
interview with nme Jenna shared that she
actually had coveted 19 while filming
that dance sequence telling the magazine
I woke up and it's weird I never get
sick and when I do it's not very bad I
had the body aches I felt like I'd been
hit by a car and that a little Goblin
had been let loose in my throat and was
scratching the walls of my esophagus
they were giving me medicine between
takes because we were waiting on the
positive results
Jenna also admitted that she had asked
to redo the scene but was told that they
didn't have time adding I think I
probably could have done it a bit better
[Music]
MGM the production company behind
Wednesday confirmed to nme that quote
strict coveted protocols were followed
and once the positive test was confirmed
production removed Jenna from the set
but despite their statement many fans
were outraged that MGM Netflix and
director Tim Burton allowed Jenna to
work when she felt so unwell while also
putting her other cast members at risk
of Contracting the virus and in recent
behind the scenes video Jenna admitted
this about the film routine I actually
felt really insecure about this I
choreographed that myself and I think
it's very obvious that I'm not a dancer
or no it's amazing
so what do you think of production's
decision to allow Jenna to film
Wednesday with covet 19. sound off in
the comments below